好 谢谢大家 不好意思 今天晚了一点
然后我们直接开始吧
我这里放了一个图 就是冰和火
然后我今天会讲一下
就是其实从我自己老本行Rates利率开始讲
然后我说一下美国现在或全球的现在一个大的形势吧
我觉得我们在两个大的宏观大周期的中间
但是这中间确实在目前的情况下就是经历了这种冰和火
然后讲一下利率 说完以后我也会讲一下
最近对Crypto市场的看法
Crypto和A股市场吧
我这个都会最近带一下
因为上周讲Crypto可能就讲了10分钟
有些信息点时候很多人问到
就是最近有很多的利率是我们老本行
然后最近有很多投资人也问到利率问题
其实因为降息有不少人其实是看多债的
看多债的所以觉得利率往下掉
这年期可能要往下掉
我这以前说一下大致的一个
我对Jackson后之后连储的一个看法
然后我对利率的看法
首先Jackson后之后连储的市场上pricing
大概在2027年中大概百分之三的发放率左右
所以我觉得这个是相对来说比较费的 比较公正的
市场现在你看右边就是我对于有几次降息
这个是市场定价有几次降息
所以基本上觉得9月份是固定的一次
然后10月份一次 12月份一次
今年三次 我觉得这个概率蛮大的
就是这个也是一个比较费的定价
至少在9月份的话我看是肯定会降息的
就大概率是会降息的
但是降50个基点这个可能并不是特别大
然后对于连储的态度我认为是这样子
最近市场上有很多的传言就说法
特别是行政部门
就是特朗普行政部门包括Belson包括
因为其实本身Jackson
Jay Powell也可能明年26年也要卸任
所以有很多对于后面连储主席会怎么样
要选什么样的人
然后短期里面那个行政部门
像那个美人储施压有很多这样的新闻
使得市场认为他会比方说大规模降息
或者不一定是大规模降息吧
就是在这个今年三次降息之后
连储会把他利率拿到很低的一个水平
就是我们认为一个
我们叫equilibrium rate
或者我们认为一个平均衡的利率
可能要降到过去这样百分之一百分之二
这一点事情我认为是没可能的
反正现在好像小
那么这个吴外湖谁做连储主席
先说一下这个行政部门
对于美联储的一些宣泄
就是我觉得行政部门对于美联储宣泄
中间有大部分的原因
是连储在上一任选举期间进行了降息
然后Trump 川普认为
JPAL是自己提拔的人
然后又去帮了那个拜登居降息
帮拜登助选
然后让拜登的股票就股票涨得比较多
让拜登能够有机会选上
是吃这个醋
然后在自己的任上
现在这个情况下又不愿意降息
他take everything personal
就是这个人是把他当成一个个人的原因
而不是完全从经济面来看
但是美联储不管谁在任上
我认为就算你选Trump
Trump明年任命几个自己亲信的人
那么这些亲信的人可能会像Belson一样
能够在Trump面前跟说的上话
其实Belson也是反对那个关税的对吧
所以他是Trump的人他说的上话
所以他能够劝得动力脑
所以我觉得在明年的情况下
不管谁在连储的位置
还是会比较终可能看在这个市场
或者是比较理智的去看在降息这个问题
我们如果是希望他有一个持续性的
猛的降息
我觉得都可能非常喜欢非常小
这个我个人看吧
就很难
那么为什么
这就回到我们现在看的两个宏观的大周期
这也结合债券的问题来说
那我觉得首先我跑出我的看看
我觉得债券率率现在到头了
4.05
昨天好像是4.7吧
068好像是
4.05
这个利率到头了
你要债继续涨
可能性很小
我觉得这个就是
我觉得对我来讲是这个
是一个非常不对称的风险
就是债的利率
十年期利率要继续往下跑
不管他降息降多少
那个继续往下跑
然后我认为连储的equilibrium
在3%
这种情况下
他的这个空间已经很小很小
就是债的空间很小
哪怕他后面有很多人说
他停止QT
或减少QT
我觉得这个都很正常
QT就是Quality Tightening
那个就是连储
那个连储卖债
就是
但相当于我手上有的头
所以把它清出去
然后那个从市场上收回的东西
QT
即使他减少QT
我认为十年债也跑到头了
那为什么
本质的原因在于
我们这个宏观大周期是两个
一个是AI和算力的大周期
这个是主导我们现在股票市场长了很多
包括我们
我不管市场多差的时候
其实对于AI芯片股都还是
我觉得要网看一面
不管多差都要网看一面
这个就因为我们在这个宏观大周期的
芯片周期
第二个宏观大周期
就是Physical Expansion
这个Physical Expansion
不光是在美国
我们最近如果看那个政治上的新闻的话
包括我们觉得法国的
其实National Rally也是希望去Cut Tax
对吧
然后中国
包括欧洲
包括那个德国
它是一个全方位的
我们叫采证的之处
这个大的周期
并与伙的周期是
我们在2008年到2009年
是并的周期
就是我们要Delaverage
要去放感
这个本质的原因是
其实到2008年19年之后
移动互联网的革命
没有提高那么多的效率
然后全球的人口
又是相对来说比较负面
所以这个周期里面
就是需求不足
其实一直
一直是很大的原因
就是很大的推动力
那么在移动互联网
没有增加那么多效率
不然
没有像互联网革命一样
那么在互联网革命之后
其实市场上累积了很多的这个杠杆
那整个08年
国际financial crisis之后
很多的杠杆要去去杠杆
所以我们一直在和
宾河期做搏斗
就是我们需求不足
这利率是很低的
那个利率很低
也应付了人口和效率
因为人口和效率就是增长
你人口再减少
效率没有增长很快
那利率就应该很低
因为你要用这个利率来维持
2%-3%的增长
是这个是过去的周期
那我觉得这一轮周期不太一样
因为原来的放出刘东欣
央行放出刘东欣的货币政策
效果没有那么好了
所以从19年之后
大家发明了用财政政策直接数学
就财政政策直接数学
在19年这个pagnemic的时代
其实已经完全证明
它会直接导致通胀
所以现在我们在一个财政支出的
一个大周期里面
这个周期是非常像
中国2008年到2018年的周期
中国2008年开始进入财政周期
所以其实中国2008年
是进入了财政和货币双周期
两个都在搞
但是财政周期
中国因为地方政府
政府的影响力比较大
所以最后的结果是让
那个居民的可支配收入
交到了完四十
四十出头一点
然后让财政周期
把所有的物价给搞起来以后
最后不可收拾了
那个但是财政周期要走一段时间
没有那么快结束的
所以在欧美来说
我觉得财政周期其实刚刚开始
所以在一个大的财政周期里面
火的行情是很重要的
就是我觉得我们在未来几个月里面
我前两天发一篇文章说
就是我们在未来几个月里面
可能会经历我们对通缩的恐惧
也会经历我们对通脏的恐惧
这个是说因为财政的支出
其实不会让通脏
维持在太低的水平上面
所以你说四点零五
就说现在时间在四点零五
我觉得四点零五是一个到头的行情
那个你在财政需要大规模周期的时候
是一方面是有通脏的担忧对吧
对于长端
长端来说
长端率率其实应该往上跑
第二个是那个有大规模的债券的
就是这个融资的需求
对一年的融资需求整年的话
确实是地域去年
但是你从现在这个节点来看
往后一年那个融资需求又上去了
所以我们看到的是整体
不光是说一年吧
或几个月
说整体在财政大周期时代
融资的需求就会很大
融资的需求就不会让利率很低
这个是中国在2008年之后
已经明确证明的事情
就是中国2008年的时候
确实也应了很多钱
我们也在拼命引钱把股市要炒起来
对吧
然后要把房子连续的往上炒
但是我们的利率很低吗
不低的
其实一直到我们三条红线
搞了三条红线之后
之前那个没有经历去槓框的时候
那个财政在大规模之处的时候
地方债在以前无风险
大家觉得百分之七
觉得各种各样的理财产品
都在都有很高的水平
其实这个本质的原因就是
expansion
physical expansion
在花钱
花钱相当于对钱的需求变大
它利率不会太低
所以这个是我对利率的一个看法
就是如果我给数据的话
我觉得41%的到头好请
就是这个10年期40%的到头
然后再一个什么价位
我觉得是一个比较安全的
就是大概4.2到4.5
就是这个结合
反正我觉得我自己个人看法
是个人思想感觉
这个不一定是一定非常准确的
但是我觉得4.2到4.5
是一个费的价格
因为4.2到4.5基本上
包括了就是大家可能后面
会有一个往上的这种
就对于活
对于通胀的一个担忧
Inflationary担忧
同时的话
会对于那个大规模的发债的一个需求
的一个平衡
这个两个方面同时考虑的话
我觉得10年期债应要在那个水平
相当于说
我认为是一个比较费的价格
所以在这里对于利率操作
我觉得怎么样
就是不要去买TLTL这些东西
就我觉得你买TLT
或者是买长端站
那个收益
我认为是到头
就是你不会太高
从你放着不动
你就吃4%
比较说网友公司
你就是吃4%
然后你做资产负债平衡
这个处罢
如果是对于投资的话
我觉得这个价格4%
10年期4%不是很有心理
那么相反的Mass option
就是相当于利率的option
我觉得既然现在
大家都已经开始这样定价通胀
这样定价降息了
开始把那个
甚至把长端应为降息都已经拉下来
长端拉下来一方面降息
另外一方面经济差
对 就是那个经济数据差
那个经济数据
我待会还会说一下
那个
但是在通胀的数据
不光是通胀的数据
我觉得市场是经常会输赢的
就是对于后面
可能会发生通胀时候
或者是那个降息以后
那么大家对这个长端利率怎么看
我觉得这个是随时会输赢
你毕竟相当于
你买股票
一直有人在你拉盘
对吧
一直有人拉盘
他不一定拉得动
但是一直有人拉盘
你是不是很安静的
安全的进去
利率也是一样的
你虽然说你长端
这个利率现在掉到4.0
但是你后面一直有人发债
就是美国政府一直在发债
有大部分发债
相当于有人一直在拉盘
一直给公益
就一直在砸
所以我觉得从利率来说的话
如果是在4.2的话
就是网上的swapping
我觉得是有可能去拨一个机会的
但不是说你一定要去shot这个note
我觉得比较说你做一个swapping之类
我觉得个人的感觉
是一个可能不错的交易
就是我对利率的看法
然后这个不光是说10年期
其实包括我年纪也是一样的
我觉得long term和bally
就是bally就是中间五年
两年五年的这些利率
整个利率曲线
我觉得steepen
steepen是有可能的
但steepen应该是由前端带动
后端利率在网上跑的概率
不是特别大
就是我说一下利率的事情
然后回过头说
我认为在两个大的周期
一个大的周期
就是我刚刚讲的宏观的周期
那宏观周期展开来说的话
其实最近你们可以看到
全球的右派的支持率都在上升
那个除了阿根廷就是初选
我看好像布里诺斯阿迪斯的右派选输了
但是整体你看民调的话
右派都在上抬头
右派抬头有很多的原因
就是这个中间包括移民
移民很重要的一个原因
或者各方面的一些原因
但是本质上右派基本上采取的一个政策
都是要去减税
包括你可以看美国为例
川普就要去搞减税
对吧
他说要去减少资次
同时搞减税
但是往往减少资次是非常难
包括你看National Relay在法国的这个态度
他们也是反对physical austerity
反对那个财政支出的限制
因为原来左派的政府是有很大的财政支出
然后同时他会给自己设一些财政支出的限制
然后花的钱可能是花在各种各样的
什么ESG这些东西上面
那么右派基本上两个政策
一个是deregulation去监管
第二个是减税
那么像川普的话他就要搞减税
11月份这些减税政策可能会通过
然后明年会造成影响
所以去监管的话
对金融比方说美国为例的话
金融去监管
有上万亿美元的流动性等于直接补充到risk-based
和nerisk-based capital
这个事情我们之前提到过
讲过
所以后面是有很多
这个inflationary的力量会推动这个市场
那么在短期里面
当然你会感受到有很多这个短期里面
美国经济因为tariff会受到影响
但是长期里面就是大家都在做physical expansion
这个是个宏观大周期
是看多了宏观大周期
但是这个看多并不适合上一轮有事
比方说无脑看多
黄金看多比特币不太一样
因为利率不会太低
就回到我们刚刚讲的利率
利率不会太低
它不是一个19年这种
我们叫做physical and monetary双周期
就是财政和货币双周期
它是一个更偏向于财政周期
非货币周期
你可以看欧洲
欧洲现在ECB是不像期的
对吧
但是德国在开始做财政周期
所以更多的财政周期
意味着公司的盈利会变得更加重要
就是你要去看这些有盈利的公司
那么这就回到我们刚刚讲的第二个周期
就是我觉得是AI的周期
AI的周期
我举个不恰当例子
怎么反正现在应该是1870年的钢铁
就是对于芯片的需求是1870年钢铁
对于AI算力的需求
就是1870年的铁路或者是高楼
就是我们可以说
它明年的需求有多少
够和不够
然后我其实对英伟达也是一直有一问
就是它明年的需求能不能增长率
肯定要下来
因为今年增长表说
40 50的明年增长市场普遍预期是20
但是你要通过一个
那估值肯定要往下调整
对吧
它马距离要往下调整
但是你要通过一个更长的周期
来看这件事情
1870年的钢铁
1871年钢铁可能需求没有那么足
那个增长不高
不够高
没有更多的铁路看空
但是你确定的在一段时间里
它增加1000倍
就刚产量增加1000倍
同样的
在算力的需求里面
今年可能增加了4倍
增加了几倍
你明年增加不知道有多少
有没有新的OAI
有没有新的模型出来
模型的需求
算力的需求跟模型迭代史上有关系的
那个会不会有新的这些算力出来
不知道
但是你可以确信的在AR过程中
把所有好学生给你全部扫地出马
像当年扫掉蓝领工人
体力好的人
机器扫掉体力好的人
然后AI就扫掉脑力好的人
就是好学生
你找按部就按读书的人
应该基本都被扫掉
这个过程
包括我们现在看到
computer science
中国很多人让人家学computer science
computer science需求也没有了
这个我们之前也讲过
就是变成的需求都被AI取代
那么这个过程里面
像1870年的钢铁一样
最后它的需求是成百倍千倍的增长
在增长的需求
这个是毫无疑问
而且这个过程会发生的非常非常快
就是在几年里面
五年十年里面就会发生
所以AI的公司
芯片的公司
它确实有可能也会被这一轮
经济变差就带动下去
然后也会被那个有不同的赛道
AI有不同的赛道
你今天可能看的是那个GPU
现在更获得是GPU 对吧
那大家确算你都去买GPU
然后以后算力要精减了
可能又去看ISAC了
对吧
然后有可能又去看算法
其实算法也是一个非常重要的东西
那么这些东西其实我觉得都会起飞
就是在宏观大周期里面都会起飞
就是这个周期是颠覆过去几十年的一个周期
我觉得是两个大周期
一个是Fedecal Expansion
财政之术周期
第二个是持续性的指数增长的AI
算力和投稿的需求
并且以此来提高市场的
提高整个社会的效率
效率提高也会让利率变得更高一点
就是提高整个社会的效率
然后这两个周期
我觉得是可能贯穿未来几年的一个大周期
那么这个都是火
然后说下冰
就是我给你看一个图
这个是Hyperscale
Hyperscale就是四个云场加上Oracle
就是国门的数据
那个投资的CAPEX和他Earning Grows
你可以看到他投资是指数借贷上升
对吧
这个还远远不够他的需求
因为现在算力都不够了
在美国都没算力了
然后远远不够他算力的增长的需求
然后同时的话
投资带动EPS增加
带动Margin的增加
这个很恐怖
他不但是带动EPS增加
还带动这个毛利率的增加
就是这是AI时代
给这些公司
给整个社会
这些带来的效率的增加
就是效率在增加
收入在增加
同时的话他还在拼命的投资
这个我们08年的投资是不一样的
08年的投资编辑效率是递减的
人家现在投资编辑效率在低增了
然后第二个就是这个图
我觉得挺重要的
就是给大家看一下的是
我们现在在2025年这个时点
去看这个投资的增长率
比方说AI出来以后
你看看到投资增长率有50以上
对吧
那么2025年第三季度公司的投资
增加了3Q增加了50%
包括我其实我自己一直很concern
那一点就一表包括英伟达
包括晶片公司
明年他们的增长率会不会下降
就是增长率会下降多少
就是你不能保持这样的一个增长率
所以市场的consensus
这是根据那个公司自己公布的
这个投资的目标
然后来定的这个投资增长率
是要下滑的下去的
也就是说
其实一个公司
他不可能开年的时候告诉你
我要增加50%的投资
大家会疯掉
所以他的投资的计划都是一直在调整的
所以你可以看2024年
他的投资计划是15
只有做了55
25年是20
做了55
对吧
26年是18
做了多少
不知道
他会不会把这个曲线再给你拉平了
我觉得可能也很大
所以就是这个是一个非常不太明确的点
就是当然现在市场consensus在这里
但这个就是根据公司的业绩的预计在这里
当然白赛的consensus可能在中间
我看到已经有很多的投资报告
或者是那个行业里面的人
觉得因为大imply明年又50
这个我觉得50不太好
没有那么高
但是超过现在预期20还是有可能
可能还是蛮大的
就是因为大家这很取决于运行的增加
就我们看到前端
其实我最近几个月一直在说的就是
前端看到的token的需求
就是对于AR算力的需求
增加了非常非常快
然后现在只有等于做个不恰当的比喻的话
现在只有美国再造大西洋铁路
对
然后接着英国 法国 德国
都要去找铁路的
每家都要去找
现在房铁厂就那么太积电一架
是属于现在这样的一个状态
所以后面的AI
我觉得这个需求还是会很快的出来
就是这个是我讲到两个大的
两个大的cycle
市场的大两个大cycle
然后说一下具体的数据
然后具体数据是这样子
那个8月份的数据
能发配落还是很差
就9月份出来的8月份的数据还是很差
然后22000个人
orgust
然后我们看一下调整
调整的话
7月份调整往上调了6000
然后6月份往下调了27000
所以三个月的平均在3万
这个就gestify后面肯定会降下来
就是
我觉得不用看什么通胀
或是其他的数据
包括美联储很简单的一个态度
就是增长是大于一切的
这并不是特朗普去逼他逼出来的
就是他就是增长大于一切
如果是增长现在出现这样的问题的话
他的这个降息
我觉得概率是非常就非常非常大
然后那个虽然xnp到all time high
我们联储可能也会担心
就是是不是这个
但是连续三个月的平均
这个tells you something
所以我觉得
我觉得降息概率很大
所以说到我刚刚讲的
就是短期里面的这些东西
但是市场定价
就我刚刚讲
不过像市场定价这样
那么这个轮的数据变差
会延续多长时间
我认为是到四季度
或者到一季度
那个8月份
这个美国经济数据变差
结合美国的
比方说一些法律吧
不许小邮包寄过来
中国出来
今天早上出来的
这个对美出口数据已经一趟糊涂了
所以美国数据变差
第一个影响最大的其实是中国人
那个
但是呢
我觉得美国本身的经济数据
可能要拖到四季度
或者一季度
这个事情就怎么说呢
我可能在今年
二三月份就一直在说
就过了三万数据变差
过了三万数据变差
那是不是在后面的减税政策出来
就是11月份
它的影响也需要几个月出来
就是你具体是到1月份
1月份还是4月份
这个都不太好讲
但是我觉得四季度
一季度可能 somewhere between that
在那个中间
可能是我们数据上的一个地点
但是这个是短期的并吗
不影响我们长期的
这个两个大周期
长期两个大周期并不免化
然后我最后五分钟
十分钟
我说一下那个芯片
就说一下那个币圈的事情
纳斯达克说
那个申请就是把所有可以让股票偷空来
我之前讲到
就是美股证券RWA最大的一个问题
其实包括CD上次在香港也讲到这个事情
就是很多的这个股票
它并不能完全换回调客
调客不能换回股票
所以中间没有arbitrage
就大部分的做那个
比方说myston这些
就是做一个对赌平台
就是赌平台
你去赌美股
然后它给你做赤客准
给你对赌
myston这些都干这个事情
那么像那个SAC
如果是向纳斯达克可以去secure
这个证券
其实我觉得相当于国家队
路上做了RWA
那这个是有力量的
就是它可以把这个证券RWA
但是这个东西的结果是币圈的
你大牛是吗
不是
包括其实前两天我在也谈到
我跟几个币圈大老爷谈过这问题
就是其实很大程度上
币股
它一方面往市场输出了输出的流动型
它一方面像那个就是Crypto市场
像去块链市场吸收流动型
我去买币股
我就不需要去买ETH了
ETH还没干完
币股还有干完
涨幅还比ETH更大
对吧
然后我直接可以挣钱户
开户我就可以买
所以其实包括Robinhood
有很多流量
买这些token的流量
都是其实从币圈吸收流动型
原生的在币圈的东西其实变差了
这个对于币圈新的
新的要翻身的同时们
我觉得概率其实变得更加低了
就是你要发的新的
咪咪token
发那个oqo眼
都会难很多
就是如果说像那个国家放松了监管
那么你本身去监管的地方的
生存空间就变小了
这是意思
第二就是我这个是NASDAQ
第二个呢就是说到那个
就是它NASDAQ RWA
第二个呢
我就说到我最近有很多的朋友
就是原来做投行的
做资讯
然后我可能在两年前三年前
让他们去买两万多的时候
他们比特币的时候
那么没有买
对吧
那我身边你们电话上有很多人
我都讲你们买比特币的
之前很早的时候
然后最近后来找到我说
那个币圈有什么样的机会
然后币股能不能做
能不能自己搞个上市公司
去做币股
然后能不能去投什么样的token
我觉得吧
就结合那个今天早上
其实Bitman又去买
做了WLD的采购
就是WLD是一个小的token
相当于它是一个很小的山台币
那么原来
我说上一门牛市能够炒起来的
很大原因是整个市场的流动性事业
整个市场的流动性是以以太坊
然后来作为整个市场的基础货币
然后以太坊涨了之后
等于m2增加
然后它就这个流动性就释放到
因为它不出去
它不离开这个市场
它就释放到所有的山台币
把大家都炒起来
那么这一轮牛市中间
以太坊涨了
会比特币涨
钱就直接变成美元了
所以它是很容易出去的
所以你很难把山寨市场炒起来
那么Bitman又去炒了WLD
就把又去炒一个小币
就它一方面做以太坊采购
它一方面拿了这个采购钱
又去炒小币
所以这个非常像上一轮
要用以太坊去炒小币
再结合就是我有很多
做投行做资讯的朋友来问我
就是这个市场好不好
要进来
甚至有朋友立马让我帮他花钱
买以太坊都有
那个我是觉得这个市场到头了
就是如果投行资讯的这帮人
都能赚钱
很简单
就这帮人如果都能赚钱
这个市场也太简单
就是这帮人基本上都是韭菜
它不是做交易
这本来就不是做交易
他们做投资银行和做资讯的
所以他们看到这个机会
说明这个机会大家都知道了
那个我对这个市场会更加看待一点
就是对于三个
第一个是对于RWD的市场
然后第二个是对于很多在炒的
比方说穩定币
穩定币的公司
然后第三个就是对于币股
这三个东西我全部反侯
就是我觉得现在他们
我一直在想左脚踩右脚
币股会玩到哪一步
我现在觉得他玩不了特别长的时间
就是因为这个是一个直观的感受
因为就好像你看到一个
擦起的小孩跟你讲股票
对吧
这个感受就因为它是完全门外汗
明白吧
就是投行那帮人对于币股
是完全门外汗
所以投行和资讯的那帮人
来找我问我这个投款的事情
币股的事情
我觉得就和擦起的小孩
再问我股票差不多
因为我个人会更加看待一点
所以持有仓位的比特币
我觉得在即使在这个大的周竅
大的周期比方说SEC去
就是那个NASDAQ去
FileSEC去吹的那个digital的股票
这个汇存市场上抽走了东西
但是它确实也会让token更加简单
那稳定币也会让token
就是像那个币权更简单
所有这个东西不影响比特币的
我讲的是山寨
山寨的市场快要到头了
不影响比特币
那有可能比特币
走出一个完全不同的行情
因为毕竟我们还是在一个
physical expansion的市场里面
对吧
就是这个大周期还是没有变
好吧
好
我今天大致这样讲一下
然后看看大家有什么问题